[Music]
foreign
we are currently in Austin Airport we're
going to be flying to Nashville that's
where we're going and uh can't wait it's
going to be awesome we're going to be
interviewing Matty the Walter big Matty
walshie he's a demon at five aside also
knows what a bird is so uh we'll be
asking what what about all the birds
mate oh and Colin Wright as well he
knows what a bird is
[Music]
like to be the first to welcome you to
Nashville Tennessee
[Music]
we are here just finished
we're here at the daily wire Studios we
just finished our brilliant interview
with Matt Walsh about what is a woman
talked about the feminist stuff you some
of you feminists are going to enjoy it
uh or not no probably not angry man yeah
quite I mean that's what they do how
many students they're feminists really
exactly anyway yeah so uh looking
forward to the backlash but it's a great
interview it's half an hour it's going
to be a lot of fun and now we're off to
get some dinner exactly see you soon
[Music]
all right so we are here what is this
place called party bees Patty bees so
this is supposed to be like the best hot
chicken in Nashville or one of the best
so we're here to smash them of that
because we're very hungry it's been a
long day we had a flight in the morning
we interviewed Matt Walsh now we're here
queuing in amazing bridge style exactly
mate so what we've done Matt told us
explain to us what a bird is and and
we're going to a chicken place sorry I
just splashed water all over you so
we're just gonna find out what a bird is
in here because it's chicken do you get
birds chicken women
but I'm gonna have tent three jumbo
tenders with two sides there's my side
choices inside a creamy coleslaw and
southern greens I'm gonna have it hot
Anton are you gonna drink alcohol might
have a beer yeah oh a beer they've got
dirty bird fries mate exactly some of
them
especially with the fries exactly on the
side
[Music]
it's Paradise
can I have some grilled tenders please
no no
all right so we'll have two portions of
bread
right I imagine if you said no but
anyway
three whole weeks does that get have a
lot of meat on it so it adds enough that
will fill you up
okay let's do three whole Wings
I'm gonna go medium because I'm weak
Roger for your Francis about the choices
you made well Life Choices mate
absolutely devastating if I've got
myself into a proper career early on I
could have bought property I came out of
basically the biggest capitalist Boon
ever with nothing is that what you're
talking about oh what the chicken yeah
delighted mate really good the many
blessings that we've had on this trip
the many blessings are coming our way
the opportunities that we're being
presented with maybe be truly grateful
for what we have
what I've got is I've got three massive
wings and we've also got side so here
goes southern greens because he's I
don't know what's wrong with him yeah
and coleslaw and cold still we've got
bacon and cheddar grits no idea what
they are but they'll probably kill you
in about 20 years we've got mac and
cheese and I got a potato salad so we're
going to share all of it and there's
some kind of Nashville comeback sauce
it's felt in a reassuring way now yeah
that's it we're gonna smash some of this
we've said Grace here we go
it is fantastic and it is worth the
heart attack that I'm gonna get
[Music]
so basically we went out yesterday had
the local oh we owned it I didn't
realize we're wrong mate what are you
doing with your baseball game this is
what the kids are doing it looks cool on
kids you're 40 years old I identify as
28. can I have the bulgogi bibimbap see
that natural hold off the tongue anyway
we ran out for Nashville uh Hot Chicken
yeah and we all woke up very content
with the experience most parts of us
were yeah some parts not so much so we
decided to have the healthy option
that's why we came to Korean where we're
having a bunch of fried stuff today is
our one day off on the trip God knows
how many days we're having a rest we
need to wash some clothes our Airbnb has
no washing machine so we're gonna go and
do it at a laundromat with the fine one
and then tomorrow it's Colin the right
yeah collinio we are at the national
food market and we're at this very nice
store it's called Golden Roll it doesn't
like a bit of rhyme I always thought Kim
should be a lovely name for a cat kimchi
yeah come here kimchi oh by the way we
haven't even talked about the reaction
to the big Joey episode no we haven't
because big jelly released it last night
and the UK comedy industry has been
incredibly supportive they've knocked
every minute of it yeah say of love
every minute of it we're very grateful
for us giving them the exposure they
deserve yeah and we're very grateful
back you know the support they've given
us over the years
uh no Rogan said little [ __ ] and you
agree with me
[Music]
give me a bit of punch it oh look at
that the pancher is on the comeback tour
when you get back your personal trainer
he's gonna kick your behind back to
America where you can get back again
I'm not happy Francis I just have to
approve a payment for like trains to
Edinburgh how much
440 quid and then we're going to pay a
shift ton of money to stay there and
we're not going to make any money this
is what we're talking about Rogan it's a
parasitic industry it is you know but
we're going to go in there and it's
against my ethnicity expanding this much
money yeah going to Edinburgh it's not
natural Gary it's not natural Gary
we're gonna stay up for those who aren't
as importance of ourselves maybe enjoy
and be grateful for the Double River
[Music]
almost
a good [ __ ] right there
[Applause]
what have you got there Francis talking
through the classic bibimbap which is
meat rice veg booming stuff in a bowl
really good very nice
[Music]
I had a beautiful Korean lunch it was
incredible from the bowl and what what's
it called Napoleon roll the ball and
roll it was great and we were ready to
go out and explore Nashville in the
beautiful weather except the weather's
not beautiful anymore no it's actually a
massive electrical storm which is going
to last right through the night we're
not going to be able to go anywhere so
being the self-confessed narcissist that
we both are Anton is actually a very
stable normal human being we're
comedians uh therefore we're going to go
home and watch our Rogan we're gonna put
it on the big screen yeah and just sit
there with tissues exactly enjoy the
image we were going to go walk around
Nashville film all that and stuff like
that but we couldn't because it's
pissing it down so we're gonna replace
it with some quality stock footage of
national Higa enjoy
foreign
[Music]
as you can see this is like the Brighton
of the UK lots of what they call
bachelorette parties and that's why it's
noisy mate yeah it's not a city for the
autistics mate the amount of noise here
is overwhelming yeah they would have
been an absolute meltdown over this
however he looks vibrant and pumped in
his element he's loving in yeah
foreign
Jewish
[Music]
this is it that's what we needed it's
what we came for we traveled all the way
on from England to buy one of these and
a lot cheaper than the other ones by the
way but it doesn't sort of math
do you not think like look at these
boots there is no way I could style this
[ __ ] myself but as a piece of
craftsmanship they do look incredible
they're just beautiful man it's 450
bucks for this one no way yeah right
terrible I don't like them it's not
natural to get the left one for that as
well yeah no mate just this one it might
not turned up to trigonometry in these
we'd have to hire you man no you
wouldn't they are beautiful genuinely
but 450 come on mate not having that
[Music]
all free myself
so here we are on the River Mississippi
River that's what Francis thinks we
haven't worked out which river this is I
left my phone at home because it was
making me angry but anyway as you can
see it's in Nissan Stadium the home of
the Tennessee Titans I have never heard
of them have you heard of them they're a
great baseball team mate yeah I don't
think they are a baseball team but
judging by the fact they're a football
team than neither of us has heard of
they're probably like the West Ham of
the UK you know what were you talking
about man we're the greatest team in the
world that no one's heard of listen that
is an excellent uh basketball team
anyway yeah here we are it is very
interesting like the thing about America
that at least that we've noticed is they
do everything to 110 you know what I
mean like if you want a business City
New York is like you get there
everyone's like trying to do something
you go to Austin it's like a hundred
percent freedom freedom you come here
it's all about the music it is
absolutely insane and like you were
saying man just walking down the street
there's buskers who are amazing it is
true man I tell you what I can't wait
till tomorrow we go and watch some ice
hockey in that Stadium
gonna be a pleasure
there's a lot of angry Americans
standing next to us looking at us with
suspicion so I'm gonna put this hat on
do you reckon if I lose more hair I
should just wear this on set exactly
until until we go to Turkey and get you
a transplant
Jeremy corbyn welcome to trigonometry to
be honest we did slack up like British
comedy didn't we yeah they're enjoying
it mate yeah they are they couldn't
handle the banter they basically said
that there is no problem with cancel
culture in the UK there's no problem
with censorship and that's why we should
be banned yeah
this is America hat made in China China
this is what the Donald was talking
about China
[Music]
listen to me right it's not [ __ ]
natural look don't mind it just don't
shove it in my face
church one way Gay Street the other way
make a choice exactly really it should
be gay That Way Church pedo street that
way yeah exactly that's why I'm going
straight
all right we're back in the Center of
Nashville we had a good rest last night
we're here to have a bit of lunch and
get ready for our fantastic interview
with Colin Wright yes we've got an
interview with colino we had a wonderful
bit of food yesterday didn't we yeah it
was oh man it was great Cajun cooking it
was absolutely Sensational and and not
only that we've had a little bit of
entertainment today because the club
Francis hold on we've got to explain to
people yeah so what happened is that
when we went on big Joey we explained
that the way the comedy industry works
in the UK and the fact that like
comedians will try and cancel other
comedians for having the wrong opinion
yeah and the comedy industry reacted
brilliantly to us didn't they yeah they
do they came out and they proved us
wrong by trying to cancel us exactly so
there's a group of them right now
including somebody from the annoyed
comedy Association who is working with a
group of other comedians some of them
have been on TV to get us canceled from
our agent Bush proving us wrong once
again but also we should say we had some
messages from some of our comedy Heroes
yeah some of the top comedians in the
world saying we did well on Rogan we
were right to call out some of the
[ __ ] yeah so we're having a great
time we're gonna have lunch we're gonna
smash the interview with Colin right
come on
[Music]
the many blessings are coming our way
and also the challenges that we are
about to face where we'd be truly
grateful for everything on this
wonderful journey of ours amen amen I
got Caribbean was it Caribbean hot
Nashville hot National hop which is the
second highest on the Old Spice summer
he got middle of the road because he's a
conservative
[Applause]
in the middle of the road let's not
change anything because change is bad
and you've got the spiciest one you just
don't like a normal bowel movement I
mean that's your problem so anyway he
likes his bowel movements like he likes
of women but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've got my rock and roll moves
[Music]